good morning everyone i'm jeff
blankenberg welcome to alexa and friends
uh as we do most thursdays i am here
interviewing someone from the world of
alexa
and today i have the good pleasure of
joining dilick hakane tour
who is a senior principal scientist on
the alexa ai
team so delek thank you for being here
uh hi good morning thank you very much
for inviting me jeff
i'm glad you could be here so i i know
that i prepared you a little bit for
this but we have a set of questions that
we like to ask on this show
and um i'd like to i'd like to start
with those just to get you a little
comfortable and and get you to
tell us a few stories before we get into
some of the the more important things
that we want to cover today
so one of the first questions that i
like to ask everybody that's on the show
is if you could have any superpower
what would that superpower be and why
that's a very good question so when i
was younger
i would think if i was fluent in all of
world's languages that would be very
cool
fluent in all languages that would be
cool yes that would be
exciting as i get older these days i'm
thinking
more like what if i don't have to sleep
there are so many things to do not
enough time never ever enough time
so wow that's a new one i hadn't heard
before uh
the superpower you're describing is the
that i would not need to sleep i could
just stay up all night
i can do all the things that i need to
do whenever i need to do them
i gotta say you've you've got something
there i could certainly use some more
time
and i look at those hours between
midnight and 6 a.m every day and i'm
like
those are six hours i could have done
something cool um yeah
man that's a good one often times they
are the quietest
calmest time yes yeah you don't have a
lot of the distractions that we have
otherwise
wow that's a really good one i like that
uh all right so
second question and this is often to
give insight to people
about uh how how you live your life i
guess
um i'm gonna offer three things here you
have your car
you have your desk and you have your
bedroom
of those three which one do you find is
consistently the messiest
it's absolutely my desk
uh all right so is it just do you have a
constant churn of paperwork
or is it just that things just kind of
end up like i i know i oftentimes will
have like a half
half empty can of soda or something
sitting on my desk just that kind of
stuff accumulates what's your what's
your mess generally
both of them sometimes a lot of
paperwork things that i read
uh switch back and forth but also things
that i kind of like use
in um to to calm me down or
to just take a little bit of a rest and
so on
um all right so now now we have to move
on to my favorite question
and this one definitely has to come with
a story i want uh i want a good
description of
exactly how you think about this but the
the question is uh imagine you're
trapped in
uh like a long alley and at one end
is a very aggressive horse-sized duck
and at the other end of the of the alley
is
an angry mob of duck-sized horses
and you can only go one direction but
you're gonna have to fight your way out
which direction do you choose
i would go from the direction of one big
horse-sized duck i mean they both sound
cute
yeah i would worry of
stepping on the horses because we have
cats two cats
oh yeah and uh you worry i think if
they're like hundred
yeah no i totally understand that i have
um
i have a um
well we have a couple of cats in our
house but we also do a lot of cat
fostering
and so well kitten fostering and so we
have a lot of very small kittens
that generally live in a very nice
segment at large space in our basement
but um as they get older and like we're
actually taking them back to
the foster facility today they've grown
a little bit they they're more active
they're jumpier
and they can run around the house like
crazy and so you'll just walk through
the house all of a sudden you will just
punt you don't even you don't mean to
right but they just run right in front
of your foot and before you know it
um man it's uh it's a lot of fun to have
him here but sometimes you feel bad when
you're like i didn't i didn't mean to
kick you i'm so sorry
so yeah i can i can see that so my my
perspective on the horse-sized duck
is that i would really want to ride it
um
oh i keep pushing my audience i hope
this happens at some point
i keep pushing my audience i want to see
like a majestic painting
of me maybe with like an alexa flag
carrying it in the air but riding a
duck-sized horse
through maybe the background of your uh
of your stream
like you know through a wooded forest or
something leading people into battle i
think that would be uh
i think that would be pretty fun
uh okay so let's let's get into why
we're really here i like silly questions
but it's fun to uh it's fun to talk
about
some interesting things too so i i don't
know that many people
uh have necessarily met you um
but you you are working on some very
very cool things at amazon and so i'd
like to know this is one of my favorite
things to ask people when they come on
here
is for you to tell me a little bit about
your career path how like
you made a bunch of choices uh along
your career both in education
and in um in your professional life
that got you to be a senior principal
scientist at amazon
so what's what's your origin story how
did you get here what's the what's the
path you took
what did it look like
so um was always very interested in
languages interaction between humans
but i was also interested in computation
computer science
during school maybe i didn't think much
of like oh what about like machines that
can talk but as i started grad school
and i was lucky enough there were people
at the school working in
in those topics i got more and more
interested in these topics
starting with machine translation moving
more and more towards
conversational dialogue systems after
graduate school it was always like
where can i grow learn but also
impact and influence the world so that
basically
drove the decision of where i work
and yeah so that's that's that's why now
i'm at alexa
got it so so have you have you had any
other interesting roles prior to amazon
that
applied to this in any way uh yes i did
work at
like my right after school i joined atnt
uh research uh in new jersey uh after
the bell labs
uh time uh was mostly conversational
systems but for the purposes of customer
care
and well we we actually built
the very first dialogue system that
talks to a million people
in a month that those seemed like very
large numbers back then
then i did a work in international
computer science institute at uc
berkeley
for some time again focusing mostly on
conversational interactions
understanding human language then i
joined
microsoft research google research and
now alexa
very good all right and so i would
imagine you probably had some
interesting schools behind you
where did you go to undergrad where did
you get your graduate degrees from
yes both of them are from turkey i grew
up in turkey
and went to a school in turkey during my
graduate
years i did stay some time as a visiting
researcher at
carnegie mellon for some time at johns
hopkins
and sarah international in california
wow very good
we were almost neighbors so i i live in
columbus ohio
which is not very far away from where
carnegie mellon is uh
yes that's uh that's wonderful that's
that's actually one of the schools that
my daughter
is looking to get into and that's
actually a an interesting transition
as we as we talk about your background
and where you went into
um for me certainly encouraging more
women to get into
technology careers is something that is
really close to my heart i think i don't
know if i've mentioned it here but i've
certainly told people
uh last year i uh i with a team of four
other people started
a uh tech women in technology
scholarship right to help women that are
coming out of high school
that want to go into technology careers
help them defray some of the costs of
going to college
it's been a really important thing for
me but i know that this is something
that's important to you as well
so i'd love your thoughts on how the
industry could
encourage and attract more women to the
industry
first it's really great to hear that
thank you very much for doing
encouraging young females to join
technical schools
and i like that for a specific reason
because i really believe that it starts
early
on we should be encouraging when when
students female students are young
because there is no reason for them to
not be successful
or engaged or enjoying the technical
fields
they just need i feel a little bit of
encouragement
and and that's when it starts usually so
i think industry could do
could support schools uh could take
active roles
starting from middle schools or high
schools they encourage girls
uh to join uh these sort of fields
organized maybe teaching sessions
and so on i always volunteered to teach
at my daughter's school
yeah i tried to prepare something fun
and engaging
i think internships could be another one
because my daughter keeps asking me like
when am i gonna be an intern
uh so internships for high schoolers i
think that's something very interesting
and
uh that could be yeah yeah i think it's
it's interesting
when you look at um the job like the job
uh landscape right there's so many
things that that students think
they could do but they're often very
restricted by only the things that
they've seen right that's why so many
children if you ask them when they're a
sixth grader what they want to do
they're like i want to be a teacher
right because they they they see
teachers and they see what teachers do
but they don't have
uh like nobody has the perspective in
sixth grade they're like
you know what i wanna be i wanna be a
software project manager like that's not
that's not a thing that really stands
out to them unless maybe their parents
do it
or an aunt or uncle or something and so
um i think that we need to give
opportunities to students to be able to
see like
my job to my kids my daughter's 16 my
son is 12
and um my job to them is that i sit in
front of a computer all day but they
don't really
without like sitting down and showing
them what i'm doing and like
look at how i'm solving these problems
and i'm writing in this whole other
language
that computers understand like that kind
of stuff i think um
is deeper than they would get just kind
of looking around right
to me to them it looks like i'm just
sitting at a desk all day
yeah absolutely um so are there other
things that we as the industry
beyond internships and uh like
introductions are are there things that
beyond getting the like getting to them
early i guess maybe is the right way to
say it
but beyond that are there things that we
can do today
to encourage and retain women to stay in
the industry because one of the things
that i understand about this
is that many times there are a lot of
women that are very interested and very
passionate about this stuff
but they are consistently repeatedly
systematic systematically we're told
that they should try other things right
i really want to get into software you'd
be a great project manager
like that's that's the kind of
encouragement that they get when
realistically like you could be just as
technical as the boys
um but they're not encouraged in those
same directions right is there is there
anything we can do
that we can solve today without having
to wait for a 16 year old to become a 25
year old
i think encouragement that's the more
important thing
being role models making them
letting them get to know the role models
i think showing some of the conclusions
outcomes
from the work because it's not just
sitting down all day in front of a
computer actually something fantastic
comes out of it at the very end
of course it's painful but i mean
sometimes it could be
but it's it's all worth it um
that no that's great thank you okay so
so last month
i had uh prem nadarajan on here uh he's
the vp of natural understanding at alex
ai
and um we talked a lot about natural
understanding and conversational ai
and he gave us an overview of kind of
the the research that his team works on
um from what i understand you are very
very focused on this conversational ai
problem
um and it's it's often described as like
one of the hardest problems in ai
so do you agree that it's one of the
toughest ones
and why absolutely
it is one of the toughest problems in ai
so i think
uh first of all uh languages are
ambiguous
when we say something oftentimes they
are so flexible that
things could change things could get
multiple meanings
us humans we oftentimes interpret what
is being told to us
through using common sense reasoning
through using whatever is happening in
the context
through single signals not just in the
words but also
in the in the speech of the things that
are told to us
and so on when you take all of these
together
then try to understand then
you could probably solve the problem but
it is very challenging especially things
related to reasoning
there are four uh they are harder things
to do um and i sometimes think to myself
even like us
humans when somebody says us something
i'm not hundred percent sure we all
understand what is being told to us
right but we somehow know how to get
around it or
often times hopefully uh or we get in
trouble right
this is something that happens to me all
the time actually um when i'll watch a
movie
um i'll watch the movie and i'll really
enjoy hearing the whole story and going
through all of that but then later
i will see people pull pieces out and
they'll be like do you remember when
this person talked about this
or when this person said this thing and
i'll be like no i never
heard or saw any of that i'll go back
and watch it be like
i think naturally and you probably know
this far better than i do
humans tend to ignore the things they
don't understand in a conversation
and focus in on the words that they do
and so you
you'll hear a word and your brain just
is like i don't need to know
like we'll just infer context without
using that word
um and only later are you like oh wait
they said that word i've never even
heard that word before right is that is
that
common do you think oh it is very common
absolutely
and then there's other signals in the
language though like when i don't
understand the word because i'm a
non-native speaker of english for
example
i kind of like try to use the context
try to just make sense out of it right
um and if not focus on things that i
know certainly oh that's perfect
um so i actually have a really good
question from the audience that i would
love to ask you
um and i think this this is great to get
your perspective on
the question is um what are some of the
differences that you find because you
just kind of mentioned this
in developing nlu in your native
language versus english
do you find yourself presented with a
new set of challenges because you're
working in english rather than your
native language
yes so i'm a native speaker of turkish
and
turkish is a morphologically complex
language we do form
uh verbs from nouns or adjectives from
verbs and so on by just adding suffixes
to the end of the words that basically
tells me that
and and it's it's it's it's both
derivational and inflectional
um and that but that basically tells me
that the size of the vocabulary in the
language is infinite because we can keep
forming words like we can keep very
very long words in turkish so that and
and then there are also other certain
rules more regular rules like uh
level harmony and so on so then the form
of those suffixes could change
depending on the words that they are
attached to
so those are mainly challenges in
turkish that make it
that make it harder to process but at
the same time uh
we do speak uh more like like
what we see is what we say uh so words
do not really have different or or
combinations of letters do not really
have different pronunciations
uh in in different contexts so in that
sense
it's a little bit easier but um yeah so
but
i would say that the most challenging
part of turkish is the morphology
got it and so do you find yourself as a
native turkish speaker
do you are there interesting challenges
that you face working on nou in english
that maybe
a native english speaker would not face
um like getting like having to dive into
the nuance of english
um certainly
so i do feel like maybe there is so much
ambiguity
around prepositions uh in turkish they
are like very
clear as i use the language i kind of
feel like oh
it's like there's some confusion in
there it's not
obviously clear to me and then when you
look at when you're processing
uh trying to understand english
utterances
you can have that sort of form of issues
um
yes that i guess that comes up to my
mind i didn't want to cut you off there
so that's that's great
all right so now now we get a big like a
big
um overarching question which is like
if you could describe for me you can
take as long as you'd like to do this we
have plenty of time
um what what do you consider the current
state of conversational ai
so currently uh we could
and now i'll i'll focus on maybe two
areas
uh customer care centers or virtual
personal assistants
uh somewhat slightly different currently
we can understand the intentions of the
users
if they're from a fixed set of
intentions like in customer care centers
and then we could understand the
arguments associated arguments with
their intentions we could handle
simple things uh same thing for virtual
personal assistants we don't have a
problem understanding
intents like like uh setting an alarm
uh with what time you're supposed to set
an alarm
or we don't have problems understanding
and answering questions
factual questions given the knowledge on
the web most of them at least
and we do we can achieve simple tasks
for users uh but that's mainly it okay
um and we do have some
translation capabilities as i think more
and more about it for uh conversational
speech
but of course not at the level of humans
yes
yeah i think uh it's remarkable to me so
i spend most of my time
um talking to developers about
conversational ai
and building alexa skills things like
that and
i often describe for them that they they
have a natural
a natural language understanding engine
running inside their own bodies
all the time and if we could only model
that right uh
it would be amazing if there are many
times where i talk to alexa
and i say the equivalent of something
like i'm fine
right and all of us everyone watching
right now knows
whatever he just said he's not fine like
there's something wrong
in the same way that you know your
spouse or somebody like that might say
the same thing and so
um we're operating on natural language
understanding all the time and it's i
think it's really interesting to think
about
how a computer tries to do that same
thing using words and tonalities and
and stuff like that because it's man is
it hard
it just sounds like it's such a
challenging problem to be able to infer
and i think maybe once you have the mass
scale of utterances
another example i use is when someone
says to you hey what's it like
um we all kind of know they're asking
about the weather
but there's no context in that in those
words to suggest that they're asking
about the weather right
uh those just sound like infinitely
challenging problems then there's so
many possibilities for those kinds of
things
um so it's it's always very very
interesting to me to see
to talk with folks that are solving
those kinds of problems uh okay so so
related to conversational ai then
um what are some of the opportunities
that you see for
ai systems in the future for
conversational ai systems and
well let's start there so what kind of
opportunities do you see for
conversational life where do we see the
the next steps in the next two maybe
five years
i think accomplishing more complex tasks
tasks that are related to each other not
asking the user again and again
what the connection between them is
being able to switch from
task oriented interactions like i want
to book a table let's say
where there's an api i'm talking to it
but switching back and forth from
non-task related things like
for example maybe i want to know if they
have outdoor seating or
i want to know if there is some parking
nearby right and the api may not be able
to provide me such information
being able to switch back and forth from
the what the api can provide
to what the real world knowledge can
provide
to the user i envision we will have more
flexible more natural conversations
in the in the shorter time span like
that
being able to switch back and forth uh
easily and frequently
learning things from user is a very
important area
learning things from multiple users that
we can generalize
to many people i have this this one
example we have the
wildfires often times in the fall season
all of a sudden the weather gets
uh very dirty right so then i have this
intention like what is the air quality
index uh if it is not encoded these days
it is but
then how can i actually teach how to
look it up or how can i teach my mission
to look up
the grades of my daughter and then
informing me if something there is
that needs attention is happening and so
on um
these tasks do uh depend on the person
it may be imp
they may be important for one person not
for the other but if we can all teach
uh that that could actually help benefit
all of us
so i do envision some form of
learning from users through interactions
could happen in the next
five years i would like to see some more
situated interactions right now the
devices
are uh are
static they don't move around i am
really looking forward to
devices that could do more things for us
so that and
and and having interactions
conversational interactions uh with them
that's
to teach that's it to accomplish so
that that's actually a topic that's
that's near and dear to me so
just yesterday we had alexa live uh
where we had a bunch of interesting
releases and announcements
and one of the things that the talk that
i got to give was we called it um
the idea was about having alexa on the
go right which is kind of what you're
describing there the ability for alexa
to go with me places
and with some of the devices that we
have available like the for the echo
frames and the echo loop and the echo
buds
um i have found that it it changes my
entire perspective about how i use
a virtual assistant when it's in my ear
versus when it's a device sitting on my
kitchen counter
and it's it's more i don't know if the
intimate's the right word but it's
it's a more interesting private
conversation the thing that i really
want i know we always talk about the
the star trek computer but what i really
want
is a a brain supplement
right i want i want there to be because
everybody has some voices in their head
that are talking to them about a number
of things
i want a voice in my head that's just
all the information i need so when i'm
talking with a friend
and they say hey what was uh you know
what was that guy's batting average in
1986 i can be like
oh it's 297 right like i just know the
stuff
because i have this thing that can bring
information in i don't actually want to
get surgery and
have all that plugged into my head but i
do feel like there's times especially
when
i travel a lot for work and i'm walking
through the airport
there's a great skill by a company
called tripit
that knows all of my travel information
right they know all of my flights they
know all my hotels
and as i'm getting a connection i can
get off of my plane and i can say
i won't say the name but i'll say uh
what gate is my next flight at and say
oh your
uh your your next gate is 10a and i'll
be like
now think about what you'd have to do
otherwise i'd have to stop like get out
of the traffic of the hallway
i'd have to flip through my phone figure
out what gate it is but
that voice was just in my head so i
could just keep going
uh in the case that i did i had to stop
and turn around because i was going the
wrong direction but
generally that's that's how it's
supposed to work right is that i have
that
mobility with me i have the the
assistant with me all the time
uh i think that makes a huge difference
yes absolutely absolutely it's similar
for me as i drive for example i'm
supposed to pay attention to the road
after a long day of work i can think of
like oh i should have done this i should
do this i should do that right
by the time i come home i cannot do it
on the way
by the time i come home it's more like
oh family like it's
it's a different completely a different
time of the day so it would be
is so great actually to be able to
accomplish to
be able to accomplish some of these
while you're coming to work um
at least the simple ones yes that is a
that is a personality trait of mine that
drives my wife crazy
is that when something's in my head like
oh i need to do that
i have to stop and either talk to the
device or
punch it into my my phone but if i don't
do it right then
it's gone um i there's i'll remember
when it was due
or when the thing needed to be done that
like hey i didn't do this thing but
i need there's many times where i just
have to like hold on a second i got to
do
i got to do the thing and then we can go
back to whatever it is we're doing
because if i don't write it down it's
gone
and uh i'll regret it later
similar problem for many people yes uh
okay so so again going back to prem and
some of the conversations we had
one of the things that he talked with me
about was the alexa prize
um and the alexa prizes this really
interesting
competition for those of you that um
i think most of the audience has
probably heard of but i'd love for you
to tell us a little bit more about it
but we're talking about the the social
about the grand challenge that's coming
up
and i know you're directly involved in
this so what what can you tell us about
that
sure yes uh alex surprise is
one of the favorite topics for me uh
i've been involved with it since i
joined amazon i'm happy to be involved
with
it since i joined amazon two years ago
the competition has been going on for a
little uh for about three years
and uh this is basically a university
challenge where amazon
funds university teams to build a
socially engaging conversational system
that could talk about a range of topics
like
current events entertainment and so on
so that they can keep users engaged in
an interaction
and every year we do fund
a set of university teams we get a set
of applications
and the grand challenge is achieving so
at the end of the interaction so here's
what happens basically user says alexa
let's chat
and they get paired with one of the
university bots and they could talk as
much as they want until they say stop
at that point we asked the customers we
asked the users uh
how would you rate this conversation
from one to five five being the highest
score and
uh so the grand challenge is basically
reaching a
composite score of uh four or higher
uh from uh the judges uh and
uh the judges at least find uh
majority of the conversations uh at at
that level of
four or above and the conversation the
final rounds of conversation should
should remain over 20 minutes which i
think
is actually a challenging target even
for us humans 20 minute conversation i
mean we're we're at 31 so we're doing
really well
but i i agree uh 20 20 minutes is a long
time to hold a conversation especially
with a device
yes yes um okay so i i actually had a
couple of other
questions come in uh and if you don't
mind taking them um
do you find that there are um there any
major differences
between our like amazon's approach
to uh how we how we handle some of our
research
versus maybe some of the other places
that you've been
yes yes is there anything you can talk
about that would be interesting
sure sure i mean i've been lucky uh to
be
um at very interesting places to work
for
and also to work with a ton of uh smart
and fantastic people
at all of these places that i worked
before
but i think every company is different
uh so
there are labs where they're more
focused on research
less connection with production or there
are places where it's
purely related with production
at amazon the one of the things that i
like a lot is
you can do very exciting interesting
research
yet you could still be connected to
customers because especially in
conversational systems customers are the
key
what they want to do with the
conversational system you cannot just go
build a system which like nobody
believes it won't be interesting for you
because you won't
you won't get to see what really happens
what people would like to do
so working with actual customers seeing
what they
what they want to achieve uh is is very
possible
at amazon and in and influencing the
work
actually impacting changing the
direction of the work
it's it's an amazing place for that
reason that's good to hear i feel the
same way but that's uh
that's that's fantastic um okay we had
one more question then i want to get
into
our scholars program and some of the
other stuff that we uh
that you're working on um but one
question that came in was
what is the pipeline from research to
actual applied product development look
like
um so from the the idea that we're going
to start researching and deciding how
this is going to work and how we're
going to
solve the problem to actually applying
it to the product what is that what does
that pipeline look like
what is uh what is the process that we
go through to get from a to b
so oftentimes we work backwards from
what the customers need when i get in
the picture it's
more for me like okay here's the need
right but
and then here here's what we can do with
the current technology today
uh what are some of the challenging
things what are the non-obvious things
that
should go in there um so i focus mostly
on
that type of problems uh most of the
scientists focus on that type of
problems
but then once they start like most of
you oftentimes we form experimental
framework
uh where we could experiment with some
of the ideas that
we would like we think could solve these
problems try to
mimic um uh to the closest detail that
how
actual interaction with the actual user
would be like form a
correct experimentation framework then
um
we work very closely with other teams uh
with teams that could uh make it happen
uh but of course sometimes you still
like yours
you may still be somewhat disconnected
from how
the actual user because there's how we
imagine that people will use this
technology
and then there is actually what is in
their mind what they want to do with it
right
there are oftentimes such such
mismatches
and and there basically data tells you
like what you're supposed to do
which is you should focus on improve and
so on
no that's that's a great perspective
thank you uh all right so getting
getting back to academia we talked about
the alexa prize and how we have a bunch
of university teams
that are competing for a large amount of
money but doing it in a way where
they're building these cool
conversational bots that
have to achieve 20 minutes they have a
4.0 rating or higher like there's a lot
of
really good interesting things there but
we also have a scholars
program which hires which which um
allows academics to join amazon in kind
of a
flexible capacity can you tell me a
little bit about that program
uh yes uh so uh we uh
we have been attracting people uh
very well-known professors in academia
to
actually work with it with us part of
the time because oftentimes the academic
positions
you have part of your time for yourself
right
maybe 20 percent or depending on where
you are in the academic year
so we have the scholars program so that
we can uh
enable these academics to engage in real
world problems
uh and then work with us invent with us
uh and
and tackle those real world issues i
think it works in both ways
we certainly benefit from having the
great minds
uh uh accessible
and uh and i i think they uh
they benefit from the interactions with
amazon because i think it opens up new
uh
areas needs for them uh what about those
things that would be
uh really important in real life yeah i
think that there there is often
for better or for worse i think that
there's often a slight disconnect
between
academia and business um
and it's it's nice to be able to have
some crossover there because i think
that there's a lot
from that business can learn from
academia and i think there's a lot
academia can take back and say well
from a true research perspective this is
a very
useful thing but when we try to apply
this like there's there's
there's no business application for what
we're necessarily doing here or maybe
there's a tremendous business
application for what we're doing
um so i think that's that's excellent
so um why do you
what is the big driving reason other
than being able to bring in some of
these uh
high-level academic folks
it seems like we spend a lot of time on
kind of this industry academic
collaborative
is there are there other driving forces
behind that that that kind of
push us to want to do this more
i think attracting talent because as the
faculty work with us
they go back to school they now have um
seen the actual problems right and they
influence the students
knowing what is happening in industry so
the students get inspiration from them
so they they
they may want to specialize in the
topics so they starting from school in
the topics that are important for us
and of course they would get to know
like how amazon works
um what does a scientist or an engineer
do inside amazon so i think they take
back the
the the knowledge to the school to the
students to these young minds that they
they inspire very good i think that's
great that's very important
i know this is not real at all but i
often think about things like that
uh a lot like the character indiana
jones uh are you you're familiar with
those movies
yeah so um he is he's an academic
professor right of his story
of his story history and uh and a number
of other topics
but he also claims to be this
archaeologist which i think any
archaeologist would argue he's probably
not an archaeologist he destroys way
way more than he ever finds or or
interacts with but um he has this real
world experience
that he can draw upon to come back to
his students and share i think that's
that's an interesting illustration even
if he's not maybe a very good
archaeologist
um uh okay so so back to
back to alexa prize um because i think
we've talked about it a couple times but
even as i look through the chat here
it seems that there are some people that
aren't entirely aware of what it is or
how they can use it
so can can anyone interact with these
bots can anyone play with them and use
them if they want to
yes right now we are in the final stage
and
uh if you say let's chat to alexa any
alexa device
then you're gonna be paired up with one
of the finalists teams
and uh you can talk as much as you want
so it's
accessible to everyone and actually
every conversation counts so do please
talk to them
uh it's it's important for uh university
teams to see
uh where they can improve to to to learn
what people would want to talk about and
so
just so that the audience has some
encouragement what what should they
expect when they say let's chat
what happens i know they could just go
use their device but i'd like to give
them some encouragement about what
what they'll actually experience when
they're on the other side of that yes
yes sure certainly it really depends on
which part that they get paired up with
and unfortunately they won't know which
one they are
paired up with but each of these teams
are very creative like
they're working beyond my imagination
they have very lively topics
uh that they could talk about certainly
these days coronavirus is important uh
they can be giving some information but
there are also forms of
exciting interesting conversation topics
that they get into like if you want to
talk about movies that you like
uh or books that you like uh sports
events and so on
um all right so let's talk about the
teams because i think that this is also
interesting
um how many finalists are there uh
so we have five finalists and uh
we started with so many proposals
and we funded 10 teams this year
from all over the world and including
russia and czech republic and
five from california there's a lot a lot
of
research interests yes yes yes
um and uh yeah
very cool and so of the five finalists
can you share who the five are
oh yes sure uh uc davis uh
stanford uh you see santa cruz
uh czech tech university czech republic
trying to remember the fifth one i'm so
sorry i kind of put you on the spot
there oh
my god yes very good emery's emery's in
uh
that's in the south right south carolina
maybe
i think in atlanta okay i i knew it was
in the south but i couldn't remember
exactly uh atlanta sounds accurate yes
um okay so
how do they like how do they participate
and
let's let's start there what what does
their participation look like are they
actively working on this or is this
something that they built
and then they're just waiting for people
to try are they iterating as the as the
competition goes on
uh you mean the universities the
competitors yeah
yes they do they do they do they do
improve constantly improve
try to improve their systems as they
interact with more and more users
they get to know what people talk about
they experiment with different ideas so
we do provide them a framework where
they can
experiment they can change their
algorithm slightly and then see what
happens
when these algorithms are being used in
production
and on the alexa side we also try to
monitor what is happening and we also
try to build tools
models machine learning algorithms and
so on that would help them
uh to improve their their uh
conversational interactions with users
so that they can actually focus on those
things that are more important that we
don't imagine that we don't see
yeah to be able to start with a ground
base and then be able to accelerate
beyond that that's
uh that's excellent and so what are they
what are they ultimately competing for
what what are they what do they get out
of this competition
oh yes so we do have uh um finals every
at every challenge period we are the
third one right now
and we are going to select the top uh
team
second and third they are all going to
be getting some financial awards i think
the top one gets
close to half it's a half a million
dollar award uh for a university team
the second gets hundred thousand
the third one gets fifty thousand and we
have the larger
uh a million dollar to the university a
million dollar award
for whichever teams wins the grand
challenge of the competition
wow that's amazing so some some team is
going to walk up walk away with a
million dollars
yes yes yes and and besides that
throughout the challenge we do fund them
a quarter million it's a research grant
we do
give them alexa enabled devices
we do give them access to aws services
and
compute and other tools and and and uh
data that we
that we have and team support like we do
have an
alexa prize engineering team that give
constantly support to the university
that's great
that's incredible to have that kind of
support um okay
so so they're they're battling against
the the challenges of conversational ai
uh in a university environment we fund
them we take care of all that stuff
but let's let's talk about those
challenges right so we have
automatic speech recognition we have
natural language understanding
um knowledge ingestion there's all sorts
of things that can we can we talk or
unpack some of those
because i think especially for our
audience i think it would be really
interesting to
like on a basic level to kind of unpack
what some of those challenges
are um and and why they're so hard
yes yes maybe starting from speech
recognition because you started from
speech recognition
so in in social conversational speech
it is the utterances are not really
pre-planned it's a conversation right
you haven't taught about this
necessarily
what you're going to say so the speech
is more natural that brings up
some challenges for speech recognition
uh furthermore it's open domain it could
be any topic any form of entity maybe
things that
you haven't heard of or seen before so
there are certainly speech recognition
challenges
uh but what we want teams to focus on is
more like the conversational
understanding conversational interaction
uh challenges so uh amazon does all of
the speech recognition what we have is
the output from a speech recognizer to
textual output
from speech recognizers that university
teams are processing
so from that point on being able to
understand uh what people's intentions
are in their uteruses
if they refer to entities uh and
most of these teams are uh tap into
accessible knowledge in the world
structured or unstructured structured
being knowledge graphs unstructured
being
news stories new articles or wikipedia
articles about
certain entities or topics so being able
to
connect what the user or link what the
user is saying to these knowledge
sources
getting that knowledge integrating them
into the conversation in a natural way
these are certainly all challenging
areas and and you can imagine this is
happening when there are
errors in the sr output because of a
variety of reasons
so their algorithms their tools need to
be very robust
for speech recognition errors and
natural conversation lotteries they
could get quite long
and certain parts may have uh different
uh
meanings or intentions they need to be
able to understand
analyze that and
they need to be able to understand um
maybe certain motivations behind user
utterances so that they can demonstrate
uh some social
intelligence they can demonstrate
empathy like if
the board asks me how are you today i'm
like
i'm really very tired i don't expect it
to say like oh great like what a
fantastic situation i'm so excited for
you right
yes so that form of
understanding what is really happening
what the user is really saying
uh what is the meaning behind their
natural language understanding so that's
that's very cool
so when we get into things like
knowledge ingestion
and conversational data sets um i know
that one of the the alexa price team one
of the like surprise teams
created cobot it's kind of a
conversational bot tool kit
it's in python python actually which is
pretty cool um can you tell me about
cobot
yes uh so during the
very first year of the challenge i
wasn't there i wasn't at amazon at the
time
and it took two teams uh some time to
figure out like how to build
how to how to come up with a dialogue
system and and there are traditional
architectures and so on but for the
universe streams is the first time they
are coming up with something like that
from those learnings uh amazon the alexa
price team actually
built an infrastructure where they can
easily build a dialog system where you
can plug in your components
and it keeps track of the conversation
state which is important very important
for
multi-turn interactions and
we provide this tool to the participants
and we have seen that the development
time
for the student for the university teams
have reduced significantly once this
tool is out there it's also easier for
us because when we want to plug in a new
tool new algorithm
then we can easily plug it in and all
the university teams would have access
to whatever we are understanding from
the user references
and um yeah so it's basically a
a an infrastructure a framework where
you can just
it's a dialogue conversational system
framework where you can plug in these
components
so it has parts that enable you to add
uh more abilities for language
understanding
uh to add more abilities for response
generation or dialogue management
and and then finally um the responses
from each of these response generators
that you plug in there
uh they are marked with some uh
the universe teams can mark with ssml
markers that's used for text-to-speech
synthesis
so that they can create some more
naturalness in the output speech when
it's being played to the users
that sounds exciting i have to ask this
question only because my job is to
internally to amazon i represent all the
developers right uh when they come to me
and they ask questions how do i do this
how do i solve this problem my job is to
go to the product team and say
how do we like let's help them solve
this problem right i'm directly in touch
with the customers
but on the same token my other job is to
talk outwardly to our developers and let
them know what's going on and what's new
and
related and i can guarantee within the
next 24 hours i'm going to get a
question
hey i heard you talk about that cobot
thing how can i how can i use it is it
available
um not yet not that i know of uh
it's available for the alexa prize uh
participants
um participants yes uh-huh
um but that's an interesting idea
i i was always i'm just curious because
i know a lot of developers are always
interested
in how can they how can they take things
that
are that exist right how can i build on
top of those things because i
i find even in the the alexa skills that
i build myself
there's there's often a lot of plumbing
that i have to put into that right
um a good example is the um
the ability to repeat myself so if the
user is interacting with my skill and
they want to say
um hey what was that or can you say that
again
if i didn't write a whole bunch of code
to be able to retain
the thing that i just said and hold on
to those things i don't i don't have
that but if there was a conversational
framework
that just did a lot of that stuff for me
automatically man i think developers
would be
very keen to jump on top of that so
that's uh that's good to know so it's
it's not available today i have the
answer to the question that i will
receive
but um that's that's really good to know
yeah yeah but but you can imagine
whatever we learned we are in working on
making it available for everyone so
some of the things that we learned from
the challenge they go in in some other
programs that we have for the
alexa skills developers uh including
things like alexa conversations uh
all right so so let's talk about um
knowledge and representing and
representing knowledge this is
i know we announced yesterday alexa
entities um which i think probably ties
into this a little bit
but um when we're adjusting knowledge in
open
domain conversations that's certainly a
challenging problem right like we don't
we're not we're not fixed into like hey
we're talking about a patient or hey
we're talking about an automobile like
it's an open conversation how are teams
addressing that kind of problem
so often times they try to
link entities in user utterances
to the entities in the knowledge graph
so that they could find information
like for example if it is a movie that
the user is talking about then you would
want to know who the director is who the
actors are
you can open up topics oftentimes they
try to do those linkages and
get the knowledge and then integrate it
back in integrate what they
retrieve back into the responses that
they have to the users
the other thing that they do is
sometimes you
run out of information like like you can
talk about this thing but you want an
out switch topic
they do use it for switching topic to
related things but not totally unrelated
things
um and uh yes
so the knowledge could be tricky so most
of this knowledge is uh structured
there's also unstructured knowledge
uh then you basically need to again
match the meaning of what the user is
talking about
to the unstructured knowledge and that's
an area that my team also uh that we
also focus on
how do you get because not all of the
world's knowledge is structured like
those simple things that i said in the
beginning like does the restaurant have
outdoor dining
doesn't necessarily be in a stripe but
it could be in a customer review or
maybe
in their descriptions of the restaurant
right so not in an
easily obvious way exactly exactly so
then how can you
ingest it into these user returns as
most of the teams are trying to do
things
like this and so that's actually a dream
of mine do
do you ever think that there will be a
situation and maybe it's a hundred years
from now
where there is a pro mostly complete
knowledge graph
it's probably never possible i think
probably the breadth of knowledge
grows faster than the the amount we can
put in there
yes that's what i was going to say
because the knowledge is dynamic and
constantly changing
like people's relationships occupations
uh
they do change their agents change right
a lot of things do change
um um maybe a complete
closer to complete ontology but even
that is tricky
but certainly i mean these are all how
do you keep the knowledge
um uh contemporary
how to make sure it doesn't have
conflicts these are all
challenging problems for in general for
the builders of these forms of knowledge
graphs
i'm glad that smart people like you are
working on this rather than me because
i would just be like well it's just one
big database let's do it um so that's
that's great uh all right so i have a
couple of more questions
but we only have six minutes left this
has been a fantastic conversation
so i'd like to talk about natural
language understanding because this is
something that's near and dear to a lot
of alexa developers hearts
as they think about this and um
conversational speech is obviously a lot
harder than like what's the weather
today um are there interesting ways that
the
the teams like in the elect surprise or
or otherwise if you in your own research
um interesting ways people have tried to
address that challenge
uh yes so
there are teams for example and these
are all things that make
sense for uh processing conversational
speech
um user utterances especially in
conversational
speech certain parts may imply certain
things like you may for example start by
giving feedback
uh to the user who or to the machine
what
on what it told you right then you may
move on to another act where you're
maybe opening up as a user a new topic
and then asking questions about it right
so the teams are trying to uh
segment uh these utterances try to
understand oh this could be the feedback
part this could be where they're
where the question is and so on uh and
uh beyond that
uh they are so that would be like
understanding the acts dialogue acts in
these utterances
uh beyond that there are teams that are
uh trying to
understand the intention of each of
these units as i mentioned earlier on
like
if you ask how are you i say i'm not
that good to understand the
the sentiment behind the users that
there's maybe i don't like that movie
okay maybe we shouldn't talk about it
right like
the sentiment behind the users
utterances these are all important
things to
extract understand uh from the words
that they have
and then convert on the way
to the conversion to the responses okay
so when we talk about sentiment analysis
do you do you find and this is just for
my own knowledge more than anything
i know that it can certainly look at the
words that were used and say oh this
seems like a negative sentiment or this
is a positive sentiment or neutral
does it also have the ability to
recognize like tone of voice
and things like that uh so
these are certainly very interesting
active researchers i did myself
and in the customer care domain looked
into like the
how what people are saying and then how
they are the pros idea of the speed
changes
from their previous utterances to the
current attorneys
though i should say that in the case of
customer care interactions these
emotions
i feel are more exaggerated so there is
a lot of information in speech
for the other surprise uh we mainly
stick to the text
um yes very very good all right so
the last topic that i want to touch on
is context and this is something that i
also
am very actively interested and engaged
in because i feel like there's so much
that can be done around context with a
user
if we only have the knowledge if we only
had know enough about a user
example i always use is for a uh
for my device to just pipe up and say
hey jeff i got you a dentist appointment
for next friday
right like that that simple gesture
means that it knows who my dentist is
and it knows it has access to my
calendar and it knows it has access to
my potentially my insurance company
right there's a lot of pieces that in
parts that go together
and it was able to recognize that i
haven't had a dentist appointment six
months so it needs to take care of that
for me
so when we when we talk about context
not only in that regard but also just
the conversation
um are there any new techniques or or
things that usually people are using
uh to to address context
uh yes so certainly keeping track of
what is
happening throughout the conversation
because you may be saying some of these
things in the same conversation
and from this social bots perspective
also the type of things it makes up it
tells you
uh throughout the conversation so there
are ways to keep track of
what is being said and remember it in
the following conversation or
conversations
um uh so for example if a bot
tells you like i don't like this movie
you don't expect it like 10 turns later
i actually like that movie a lot right
that would become
that would like you would lose your
trust to this system that you're
talking to if that happens so they do
keep track of this information represent
them in some
form of there was one specific team
representing it in
in the form of uh knowledge graphs right
like as i built the persona of this
machine
uh keep uh uh if i remember it right
that was byu
um let me build up build a person of
this machine and a knowledge graph and
then keep
using that information in the future
interactions uh that form of
personalization
as you the example that you gave it's
also very important many of the teams
ask
what is what is your name right that
kind of like that little personal touch
and then they remember what books you
like or what movies or what genre you
like
uh so that you can you can keep track of
it
so from a scientist's perspective as i
look into these things
it is very important to be able to keep
track of that form of context
for use i think personal assistants are
going to be only personal when they
achieve that
that level of personalization they know
what you want what you like
they kind of like foresee before you
even think about it like oh
you know what you should have done this
or you may like this right so
they think for you basically i love that
i i again i want that thing that's going
to take care of a lot of those
like i want to think about the big stuff
i don't want to be bothered with the
fact that like do i have gas in my car
like that's not a thing i ever want to
think about
i just wanted to be like hey by the way
you should leave 10 minutes early you
need to get gas like that would be
awesome
that kind of stuff would be huge uh well
dylan this has been a fantastic
conversation thank you so much for being
here today um
just as we're wrapping up i'd love for
you to remind people
how they can uh not only learn about the
winners but interact with any of the
competitors that are currently going on
oh yes first thanks so much jeff for
having me here
uh we are going to announce soon uh the
winner for
uh this uh this year's challenge on
amazon.signs
our website please watch for the news
and the results are to come out soon
and uh to talk to the bots please just
say let's chat
awesome and we will get you connected to
one of the boxes all their devices alexa
let's chat
thank you so much again delek for being
here today and uh thank you everybody
for tuning in
uh i am actually on vacation next week
so we will not have an alexa and friends
next week but
um i will be publishing a schedule with
more guests more interesting people to
talk to you
in the very near future so thank you
guys all for tuning in and we will see
you all again very soon